ladies and gentlemen this is Lee casino
the wrestlers have selected their card
from a special deck the suit drawn
determines their groove every three
minutes we shuffle the deck to see which
suit comes next after all suits have
been exhausted the individual who drew
the choker card will be the final
participant to join the match
elimination occurs when you are thrown
over the top rope and both feet touch
the floor the last remaining wrestler
wins the match and will challenge the
winner of tonight's main event in the
future for the aew world chess mansion
curtly during the club's Dustin Thomas
max will take a freedman MJ
sunny days Brandon Cutler and Michael
Knocka Knocka
[Applause]
Michael nakagawa getting a hero's
welcome here in Las Vegas and the rules
may seem convoluted Alex but really it's
a traditional over the top rope bow wow
it really is indeed a the top row of
eliminations that's how it goes
immediately bad targeting Dustin
autonomous MJ asked and it doesn't
Thomas's Facebook Brandon Cutler
intervening indie Brandon colored the
man who makes everyone cry because he's
such an inspirational story Dustin
Thomas by the way to be noted a
bilateral amputee from the age of three
because the spine issue and look where
he is today with the hard work
perseverance
MJ jaw-jacking with Brenda Cutler as
sunny days of Michael's up nakazawa in
the center of the rink trying to bring
him up for a vertical suplex
Nakagawa though getting wide you can see
he's got the vertical oh my god that's
the oil the baby oil comes out he's
getting slippery he's getting slack
yes indeed and for those not familiar
with Michael not Izawa he is 1p
employees baby to say he practicing of
the Turkish oil wrestling technique
Michael nock is out creating a real
hazard for everybody else that's gonna
rustle later on tonight in sunny days
with the waist lock and Nakagawa all
slicked up again oh whoa
the only thing we can hope for is if he
only has one bottle left that's what we
got a squirt out like Mike on and knock
a stopper
Las Vegas his favorite adopted son go to
the midsection sitting date Oh head
punches levels knock us out takes him
off his feet
hey let's not discount sunny days his
chances of winning this this man has
been on a roll getting into the first
elimination is Brandon Cutler thrown
over the top and two inspirational
stories here sunny days and Brandi
Cutler but they are trying to make their
mark here and all elite wrestling and
what better way to do so than getting
the first elimination here and the
casino battle royale Excalibur you've
wrestled for a number of years only I
ask you is it better for the ring to be
empty or full when the diamond
that is a tough call I've never been in
a battle royal quite like this but I
would have to imagine it's better for
the ring to be full up because those are
some opponents that are softened up and
they make for easy pickings it's
literally freed up to oil dump in some
cases and now MJ have Maxwell Jacob
Freedman city Cutler to the roast Cutler
come fly elbow shot to the jaw finally
shutting the mouth of mjf indeed and
again over the top rope battle aerial
elimination rules here this again
warm-up for double or nothing you can
order it streaming live on Bleacher
Report B are alive DirecTV Dish Network
cable providers throughout the US and
Canada and in the UK and Ireland ITV box
office calm fight teeth fight TV by TV
they
to match it's like the diamonds have
been drawn and they will be heading to
the ring let's see this part of this
diamond group interesting now this now
this is panning out groups of five
quintets if you will some of whom are
maybe tag-team competitors some foods
that may may hate each other to be quite
honest with you have no reason to work
together to try to make things happen
for your chair mjf already calling his
shot saying he's going to be the champ
he's going to be the man that goes out
to face the winner of Chris Jericho on
Kenny Omega tonight and double or
nothing main event
MJ have taken him out and Dustin's just
been sitting in the corner which by the
way may not be such a bad thing for
Dustin Thomas employees looking to go
after the old Bobby in strategy of
hiding under the ring he's hiding under
the turnbuckle but Dustin Thomas is a
tenacious individual he's on the man
with with a lot of heart a lot of fight
now we have the diamonds making their
way down the ramp and Brian Pillman jr.
trying to make his appearance Oh
Cassidy just cut across the joke Mike
[Applause]
and business picking up on the ramp as
Jimmy havoc and Joey janela two
like-minded individuals teaming up and
we see the Batgirl Penelope Ford
escorting janela out to the ring
Oh
the perfect man himself short Spears
visit aw take a look at those eyes man
you see determination right after NJ
[Applause]
Freeman on to his feet went up hook to
the eye the greco-roman I quote expertly
employed
MJ at the same
so far we have not yet but Spears get in
the eyes of mjf and look at perhaps how
would you rate that one Alex oh that's a
10
ten
I'm showing Spears hey stop
[Applause]
tell he's got me back
Speirs feeling of five hear the crowd
right fully behind him as he lights up
mjf
Pam Jaya bagging off trying to create
some distance between Southern Spears
but Spears pressing the attack
[Applause]
again just light them up with chops we
should pay five four three two one
it's the hearts the heart suit has begun
[Applause]
boy mark Quinn
[Applause]
[Music]
and there
again no eliminations so far in this a
primero and an eliminate pin by the way
I don't think what mjf starched him
private parties still not in the rim
they are on the outside mark twain went
to check on isaiah cassidy they were
they might be the smartest men the match
still on the outside as glacier and
janela squaring off in the center of the
ray mjf mocking to a sure way sure 32
years on and off in this business
deserves a little respect but into a
[Applause]
cross shop catching Friedman high right
across the islands up all hell stab take
Janelle off his feet a glacier said his
experience in wrestling was going to
benefit him oh there's a lot of
youngsters sunny days comes from behind
knocking glacier the outside and days
pancake and Cutler in the corner days
looking for the elimination on nacos
Allen akazawa
holding on this is where the baby oil
could backfire his back would exactly be
delivery to hold on maybe notice he used
his elbow he didn't use
by Michael Nakagawa and Matt Jackson
cheering in the back I can hear him from
here no Michael not Gazala will not be
getting now sunny days up to the top
rope
lay sure returns to the ring is Janel
letting off glacier blowing - missed -
two shots of miss Davis frozen solid
like an iceberg and it goes out that's
it for sunny days
not so soon anymore jumping glacier over
that
Oh Jenelle a lit cigarette put on his
forehead by jimmy havoc do we have it as
a staple gun
I guess that is allowed in the casino
Battle Royale
[Music]
[Applause]
and now Billy Gunn taking Friedman to
the outside Freeman though hangs on
lands on the apron mjf shot to the
midsection I Billy Gunn Joey janela is
wrestling with a lit cigarette to his
forehead and now Brian Pillman jr.
taking to the sky take down janela
shades of his pop right there air
Pillman flying Brian jr. the promise
prints getting and I feel they're from
mjf and now Brandon Cutler
Jimmy havoc UK's on Jimmy havoc and if
you're staying up to watch in the UK or
Ireland we appreciate it thank you very
much
but right now Shawn Spears try to
manipulate the fingers enjoy tonality
three two one
they're coming to Spain marked one
trying to look suits
[Applause]
yes
[Applause]
sure
now it should be noted this is the group
of twenty there is on all participant a
wild card that is going to be coming in
his Marco stuff blower from stunts and
he's feeling of I've but mjf once again
taking center stage that seems to be his
strategy Oh dreamer eats a shot from mjf
on the apron now ace Romero charging in
it
take sunny kids Lucas Larsen dreamer
they see baby crashing in and it looks
like janela and havoc that cigarette to
the forums may have made an enemy out of
joy janella for jimmy havoc muchas horas
was playing in the ring but playing a
little possum right through with ace
Romero and after after Mark Twain and
Isaiah Cassidy private party hit that
leaping work on run into an age special
combination
one litre of elimination a bunch of SARS
an ace Romero squared off in the crowd
is stirring crowd to their feet because
Tommy Dreamer is coming back with some
plenty
and now Express cat flips Lucas soars on
the way in [ __ ] starch and Billy Gunn
to della Cutler gas leak when Romero
Tommy dreamers on a path of rage
Jimmy hammock - crusher they're from
Reimer look like havoc was gonna walk
his way through it
stood dreamers the innovator of
baby see the shirt tell eternal making
us match his own with the heart
wait if you're allowed to bring garbage
cane in the ring and
why not yeah the only rules when you
have to obey your mother by throwing
them over the top row
apparently after that anything goes
and now janela wild right hands catch a
dreamer ball across the face Mandriva
starts them across the jaw
now--let's asaurus that's private party
laughs and a double chokeslam from look
just Saurez and the party may be over
pretty soon a 13-6 close like that
the crowd counting down it is the last
man the choker
[Applause]
and the last man is the hangman Madame
page
[Applause]
he's just
[Applause]
let's say a page the guy who came into
tonight without a match as you know his
Matt's got canceled dens effete going to
the cassini battle royale and ends up
picking each other
blockbuster by page on jungle boy lives
up to his feet but you
[ __ ] you got the bad boy at the OS
marketing back to their matchup in last
September
no cracker barrels at ringside but
instead their pick up where they left
off janela told me by the way in
preparation for this hatch he only went
out to 6 a.m. today
Joey janela
yeah bit of a hangover he was out late
on the strip he was parted he was living
it up but right now does not seem to be
affecting him paid reverses him into the
world
Jessica's almost ride takes gentle off
his feet and now Paige
rates of passage that denna
he's renamed it and he planted janella
on the top of his head as paint Romero
getting lit up by Shawn Spears in the
corner but AC baby turnaround
shots to the chest of Spears as page in
lucha soros no romero block
make shot across the jaw taking down
look asuras and you can see immediately
goes down clutching that left knee
they're not the wisest move there by
hangman page
Jimmy havoc almost eliminated by Sonny
kiss but he hangs on now the two
smallest men in the match Marco's stunt
and jungle boy come on that nice Romero
touch the double clothesline stunt
watched up
[Applause]
if you are loving this action you need
to buy double or nothing it's just a
touch of a button to get that done doing
it on cable doing it on Direct TV all
over the place fight TV ITV box-office
comedy UK
pancaking jungleboy totally gone for his
sleeper but romero using weight and
momentum against him scientific
principles will win every single time by
the way this is in this is airing live
in the UK on ITV this is one of the
biggest show to take place in the
history of wrestling United Kingdom
I know it's airing late but we're gonna
we're expecting a huge audience
expecting a huge response from us and
Jack White House gonna be joining us a
little bit later on as well so you
definitely all Margaux
slammer touches got bounced out of the
ring by ace Romero and on to private
party
all three Mendes crashing to the arena
floor the replay we gonna take a look at
it
when you leave your feet that sort of
stuff can happen excalibur jungleboy or
the drop kick to the back and now he's
proud
[Applause]
and as you mentioned Alex thank you for
joining us on itv4 in the UK and Ireland
we appreciate you staying up and we
would appreciate it even more if you
stayed up late for double or nothing
coming up at the top of the hour indeed
by the way here's what that DDT plants
janela on his head once again and I TV
viewers trust me you got tips avian
coming up your hometown hero against an
megive are a little bit later on here in
the bayou
Dustin Thomas dr. Thomas has Joe
Legionella setup
Justin Thomas taking the fight directly
to Delano Thomas
[Applause]
first autonomous just amazing
yes okay
enjoy channel on right there mjf
cutting him off and mjm voice thomas up
setting on the top turnbuckle this is
dangerous territory Shawn Spears
intercepts janela look at this
[Applause]
perfect inside move by Dustin Thomas
Dustin Thomas proving that it's every
man for himself
now Thomas springing up to the top the
slingshot DDT
with the counter shop famous our own
brand and Cutler no bread of color
[Applause]
bring the coupler living the dream to
sign to an atavism contract this week
[Applause]
[Music]
well you better ashes in the mouth mjf
potat he has been such an opportunist in
this match but you can't blame them
right I mean this is his chance to get
there by lucha Soros now look just Faris
[Applause]
if you're loving this type of action
don't forget to order double or nothing
so much more to come
[Applause]
sunny kiss
that's dreamer then the tears
locomotion but bus trip sunny kiss
perfect
Oh
I'm gonna get one over on Tommy Dreamer
that easily following this Cassidy
orange Cassidy the suave 22nd that's me
laying in the heavy lather he's a zombie
dreamer he's a slob he's a slob he just
tries to persuade men but look how
effective these kicks our dreamer can't
even block him he's devastating him
right here
he's knocking out the pencil under Oh
[Applause]
the dreamer is gonna be on crutches
tonight
you can see the ice in the back already
getting prepared orange Cassidy
right hand takes them down not sure if
you care
yeah if the meter has not actually
changed did you just lost us
[Applause]
whoa whoa with this table eliminated by
Jimmy havoc hardcore legend eliminated
by a deathmatch legend in the UK we have
deathmatch legend period Japan the
United States England Germany doesn't
matter
Jimmy havoc is out for blood
other stable got kicked out of hammocks
hand now look just Aris woodchuck avoid
the TMS face breaker mjf brought to his
feet
chuckle incentive on top dog to the
white hands on havoc
- because fighting the figures on what
[Applause]
you to survive that
and here we are we down we're down to
four we are down to the final four
lucious Soros Jimmy havoc mjf and
hangman Adam Paige we've got the Joker
Hagman Anna Paige and the man that's
been in there the longest mjf in the man
with the least amount of friends in this
batch yes that's what happened to
researchers so here right and MJ have to
taken so many cheap shots goes outside
the ring but not over the top rope so he
is still eligible to win this match and
get that world title shot double lariat
duck by page and have it now pledges to
the back muchas horas all just laying in
shots to book I was the opposition
justice Larry but now no Jimmy Beck
[Applause]
ran into the waiting booted hangman Adam
Paige Oh
leaping uppercut putt a peek a hammock
standing tall send the ring he's
thinking a second acid rain maker cuts
the throat of Paige Paige reverses havoc
hangs on to the rope he's done that
tanks out Jimmy havoc Jew men actually
do my mistakes three men remain MJ I'm
still on the floor like a snake in the
grass
yeah let's not forget about him
it's our turn again Paige Duck Sauce the
way chopped to the chef bull hi rounding
me strike
catch a page in the temple
[Applause]
lucha Saurus did you see Paige holding
on to that left knee that left leg so
heavily taped up not a good situation
Paige without law progenies
[Applause]
everybody forgot about him dad
he turned away to [ __ ]
[ __ ] Jeff thinks he's won No
[Applause]
we'll hang man Adam Adam page getting an
ADW
the world championship shot he is the
winner of the first iew match he is
going to beginning the first title shot
ae w world championship gonna be facing
the winner of alpha versus Omega Kenny
versus Chris Kenny Omega Chris Jericho
tonight you need to order this match if
you have not already ITV box-office calm
in the United Kingdom and
I thought TV brother
for locales in the u.s. DirecTV and Dish
[Music]
and hangman had a paid standing tall
center of the ring he's got that injured
leg but he is coming in
but he's coming out of the first aew
match ever as the winner and he will
challenge to become the
world champion
[Music]
[Applause]